[Music]
we all love the loud house but there are
just a few things about it that leave us
feeling uncomfortable stay tuned to find
out the creator of the show's biggest
secrets new around here don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things for more great
content now under 10 things about live
house the creators don't want you to
know skinny-dipping the loud house is no
stranger to dirty jokes in fact the show
it's gotten into trouble numerous times
for all of the inappropriate jokes if
they have air but in the episode sweet
and sour the jokes went a little bit too
far what do we mean you asked well on
the episode the family goes on vacation
while on vacation Lincoln's parents Len
and Rita are running around the pool and
giggling they are having so much fun
that they end up taking their clothes
off and going skinny-dipping in the pool
when we saw this it made us wonder what
exactly was going through the creators
of the show's mind to make them think
that this was okay seriously parents
running around and playing naked how
does that scream appropriate for
children anyway eventually the parents
get caught and they try to bribe the
pool manager when that doesn't work the
family gets kicked out of the hotel have
you ever heard of a stranger storyline
for a children's show where the creators
just sitting in a room with each other
thinking hmm how can I make this show as
inappropriate as possible because if
that's the case then they definitely
succeed it Rodie to nowhere okay so we
know a lot of shows have mistakes but
seriously on some episodes of the laugh
house it's like the creators weren't
even trying make the episode wrote it to
nowhere for instance in the episode luna
finds out that she will be headlining
what is called the royal rumble of
course she is super excited with that
excitement only lasts and how she finds
out that her roadie chunk used to also
have the same dreams that she did and
also headlines the same show when he was
her age this scared Luna because chunk
is basically a bum now who lives in his
van and collects junk which is awkward
and sad but let's get to the mistake in
the episode so while Luna is performing
she absolutely slays the performance but
there was one moment of the performance
that threw us off at one point you can
still hear a guitar playing even though
both of Lunas hands are raised in the
air unless she's figured out a way to
play the guitar with no hands
we are pretty sure that that was a
mistake did the creators not notice this
mistake they must not have because we
can't imagine that they would have left
it in there no place like home school
speaking of mistakes the show obviously
doesn't care about them the creator's
are not perfectionists by any stretch of
the word another example of that is the
episode no place like home school in the
episode all of the kids are super
jealous that Lola gets to be
homeschooled for some reason they
imagine that homeschooling will be super
easy and she'll basically get the whole
day off to do whatever she wants because
of this Lincoln tries to convince his
parents to let him be homeschooled too
they agree but say if they want to be
homeschooled they have to get all of
their work done on their own
Lola then tells the rest of the kids
that if they're going to keep up with
what their parents said then they can't
wait until the last second to do their
work obviously they don't listen to her
and spend the whole week playing around
stressed out they ask Allah to help them
at the end of the week she does but then
she ends up being too tired to do her
own work because of this she's almost
sent back to regular school but the
other kids convince their parents to
give her another chance here comes the
mistake when Lola finds out she doesn't
have to go back to school she's wearing
gloves but when she hugs her siblings
she's not wearing any gloves weird right
the white hair there are so many
mistakes in the loud house that you
would think the creators were doing it
on purpose in fact they may actually be
doing it on purpose and the joke is on
us anyway in the episode the white hair
the mistakes just keep on coming in the
episode Lincoln wants to impress the new
girl in town so obviously he dresses up
like he's straight out of grease when
his sisters see that he is trying to
impress a girl they get excited and
really want to help their brother
unfortunately he won't let them help so
instead he goes to school on his own
without their help and that's where the
mistakes in the episode take place while
he was waiting for the bus he tries to
hide from misters the weird thing about
this is that Lincoln usually walks to
school fans were quick to point out this
era they also noticed that Warren the
rabbit ran from his sisters the rabbit
who was playing the chase musics dress
changed from purple to pink as if that
wasn't enough mistakes in another
episode
Lincoln convinces his sister Lucy that
she should be herself to impress guys
but in this episode he is pretending to
be someone else
makes sense hidden Mario there are a lot
of hidden messages in the route house
and weirdly enough a lot of them are
references to Super Mario why we are not
100% sure maybe the creators are just
super into Mario whatever the reasoning
behind it is Mario is super prevalent in
the show it's so prevalent that fans
have even compared Lola to Peach think
about it peach and Lola do look quite
similar the creator's haven't confirmed
the link but it would make sense if you
need more proof of the references take a
look at the episode butterfly effect and
it Lisa is wearing a red cat that is so
similar to Mario's that it's a bit
creepy it's the same color shape and
everything but that's not even the only
coincidence
in the episode hope friction luan did
something that was super similar to what
you can do in the Mario Kart series in
the episode she throws a boomerang out
our principal's golf cart and then Luna
throws a banana pill in front of the
golf cart once it hits the banana peel
the cart swerves until it spins out if
you have ever played Mario Kart then you
know that this is a move dies pretty
normal in the games coincidence we think
not the crew if you were a crew member
working on a show wouldn't you want to
include yourself in the show well the
creators probably don't want you to know
this but that is exactly what they did
in fact you can see the entire
production crew in one episode you may
not have known this if you aren't
allowed how superfan but don't worry we
watch enough of this show to point out
all of the things that you may have
missed if you have watched all of the
behind the scenes clips of the show then
you probably know the names of the crew
and cast members all of the crew members
including show creator Chris Savino are
all in the episode for Bros about to
rock of course the actual crew members
aren't on the show the cartoon versions
of the crew and that isn't the only
episode there in either in the episode
the loud this yard if they are featured
again they are the ones in the crowd
watching the game there have been mixed
feelings about the crew being in the
show on the one hand it's kind of cool
to see the people who make the show in
it but on the other hand isn't it kind
of narcissistic to put yourself in a
show that you create personally we think
it's pretty cool
world of warcraft references now if
you've been watching the loud house for
a while then you
there are lots of references to other
things on the show but one of the
references is so subtle but it seems
like the creator's probably didn't even
want us to figure it out so if you're a
gamer then you have probably heard of
world of warcraft for some reason the
creators are obsessed with putting
little ODEs to the game all throughout
the show
in the episode spell it out the show
references a world of warcraft video
that went viral in the video the players
try to figure out what kind of weapons
that they are going to use when another
player named Leroy Jenkins skips the
orientation and goes directly into
battle he yells his own name and goes
into battle while the rest of the team
tries to catch up the clip became super
popular in the episode of the loud house
the kids play a game that looks super
similar to the world of warcraft while
playing rusty shouts out his name like
Leroy did it's such a small reference
that many people probably didn't catch
it since the show is known for making
references we wonder why the creator's
decided to make this one so subliminal
subliminal promotion you know what
subliminal messages are right there are
messages that are pretty much hidden in
other messages the intent is to get you
to think of something without directly
telling you to think of it the loud
house creators are notorious for doing
this especially when it comes to other
Nickelodeon shows the episode link or
swim is actually chock-full of
references in the episode the family
goes to a community swimming pool but
unfortunately they can't seem to have
fun there while at the swimming pool a
lot of familiar faces pop up in the
background of the show if you pay close
attention you can even see Lou pickles
from Rugrats and even grandpa Phil from
hey Arnold but the special guests don't
in fair miss bitters from invader zim is
also there along with miss fowl from The
Adventures of Jimmy Neutron you can even
see Iroh from Avatar The Last Airbender
do you think that the creators of the
show are always including references to
other Nickelodeon shows as a way to get
people to watch the shows it's like they
are forcing us to watch an advertisement
within a show if you didn't pay close
attention to the episode then you might
have missed those other characters
entirely
rabbit family now that you love the loud
house you probably can't imagine a show
being any other way than it already is
that's what usually happens when you
find a show and fall in love with it but
many of the shows that we see on
television today didn't start out with
the same themes or even storylines when
the creators are making a show for
instance in the loud house the family
was originally supposed to be a family
of rabbits when the show's creator Chris
Tavano originally pitched the idea for
the show he said that he actually wanted
the family to be a family of rabbits
instead of having 10 sister rabbits he
originally wanted to have 25 of them
Chris felt that since rabbits often do
multiply it was a funny spin to add to
the show plus he really wanted to do a
show around animals after he had done
human based shows for so long so while
he was fine-tuning the show people told
him that they felt like he would have
more of a chance if the show were about
humans so he simply took off the bunny
ears and tail and sick the number of
sisters down from 25 to 10 and voila we
have the cartoon we all know and love
creator fired
can you imagine creating the show and
then being fired from working on it as
the creator of the show you probably
feel like the safest one on the set but
apparently when it comes to television
no one is ever safe the creator of the
loud house Chris Savino had to find that
out the hard way amidst allegations of
harassment Chris was suspended from the
show a day after that he was fired
completely fans were shocked that
someone who created something so
wonderful and funny to do such horrible
things four days after he was fired from
the show Chris finally released a
statement about the whole thing
on Facebook he said that he was deeply
sorry and ashamed of his actions he went
on to say that he now understands that
his actions were wrong and that he
should have known better and acted
better he also said that he has respect
for all of the women that spoke out
against him around 12 women came forward
to accuse Savino of misconduct it's
crazy to think that someone who was
doing such gross things behind the
scenes was making such a great
television show it just shows you that
you never know what people are capable
of that
for ten things about loud house the
creators don't want you to know were you
surprised by anything on the list let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
[Music]